[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today as we
talk about careers and jobs with him and
life and so forth with me and
ken together this is launch day around
ramsey borrowed future the documentary
is available as of now you can watch it
on
apple tv on google play and on amazon
prime or borrowed future dot com if
you're a teacher and you would like to
show this student loan expose
to your students after they see it i
promise you they will go to college
without debt
it will uh scare them straight
and we're here to stir up a holy ruckus
it's what we do around here and i can
promise you this uh this documentary
will uh
it's not gonna be some people not happy
when they see that what we did to them
yeah because we exposed the underbelly
of some of these places that uh have
been misbehaving for years and all shows
up in this documentary you will enjoy it
it's riveting
it's very very very well done borrowed
future anywhere great docs are found
so ken the wall street journal reads the
irs wants to look at your bank account
on your next trip to the atm imagine
that uncle sam is looking over your
shoulder as if your annual tax filing
wasn't invasive enough the biden
administration would like to look at
your checking account charles reddig the
commissioner of the internal revenue
service wants banks to report annual
cash flows for ordinary account holders
treasury secretary janet yellen is
promoting the plan and the
house ways and means committee is
debating whether to include this mandate
in the democrats 3.5 trillion dollar
spending bill mr ellen says the
reporting will help to catch wealthy tax
dodgers in a recent letter to the
committee she said the plan would reveal
opaque income streams that
disproportionately accrue to the top
yeah the re the wealthy are evil and i'm
sure they're all hiding their money in
the bank you stupid woman
seriously
well this is uh this is unbelievable had
had i not seen that this was an actual
article i would have thought this was a
spoof from the onion
this is so unbelievably outrageous
that the federal government is kicking
around the idea of being able to look
into our bank accounts let me tell you
something this is going to get nasty
right here because uh there's there's
always another way around every time
government tries to move and pivot to
take away our personal freedom uh people
figure it out and i hope some bankers
are paying attention right now because
if i i i i can you imagine something can
you imagine that this would not help
deposits
that's what i'm saying it's going to
disrupt and destroy an industry i got to
tell you the irs plans to review every
account above a 600 balance
or because that's the people that are
these are the wealthy tax dodgers here
well there's the catch it's not about
wealthy people it's about everybody yeah
it's about control
again it's time for some pitchforks to
come out i got a little bit of a little
bit of a
probably a couple of uh torches to go
with the pitchforks yes it's also a
privacy breach waiting to happen not
long ago the confidential tax records of
jeff bezos mike bloomberg and other
wealthy americans were exposed by
pro-publica
whoever leaked or hacked those records
committed a crime but the irs has
revealed nothing from its promised
investigation adding bank account info
to the irs trove would dis risk the
disclosure of savings and spending
information of political adversaries in
the same way no that would never happen
23 state treasurers and auditors signed
a letter last month opposing the plan
calling it one of the largest
infringements of data
privacy in our nation's history you
think
by the way watch this watch how this
might just flood the cryptocurrency
thing becoming an outside fringe thing
to an actual everyday thing that's why
this thing is out there i'm not
endorsing it at all i don't do anything
with it i want to be very clear but
that's where this is coming from
because of this government overreach you
watch it it's just gonna if this happens
or even tries to happen it's gonna
create a tidal wave of of mistrust and
all kinds of problems it's laughable
it's so absurd
it really is it's it's mind-blowing that
that they think that this could actually
happen
yeah and and
you know i would think
that probably one of the more powerful
lobbying groups
even for democrats would be the bankers
abs that's why i laugh and i would think
that they would put their big heel on
this and grind
because this is going to create um
a lot of cost for them
because they have to build systems to
report this to comply
this is like this is a billions and
billions of dollars of cost for the
banking industry yeah
yeah the the this my god if you got 750
joe biden wants to know it oh yeah and
first of all let me just say this i i
have no this is opinion i just don't
think this has any legs to it all it's
so ridiculous
but the emperor is officially not
wearing clothes that's where we are
right now this is such an unbelievable
tradition
yes on top of everything else he's taken
his clothes
suit needs ironing yes don't do that yes
it does don't do that yeah it's just so
absurd that this that this policy would
even be floating
but it's
you know it goes along with a lot of the
covet overreach and some of these other
things that are overreaching
constitutional rights
um
and it's been going on for some time yes
and uh
just how much
before people bow up on it um i think
this would do apparently there's a
weather problem with southwest air right
now yeah weather the weather everywhere
southwest air is flying is bad yeah and
so uh they're struggling with weather
and everywhere they land is a problem
yeah so yeah this is gonna this has
these
statements and policies and supposed
things even if you don't implement them
if you just toss it out there like a
trial balloon that has a grenade
attached to it
it still has implications that's a great
point you know reverbs through these
industries that's absolutely a great
point dave this is a threat to privacy
a threat
right now it's a threat it's not an
attack yet but it's a threat and i don't
know if there's anything more private
than our bank accounts you start talking
about people's money
i mean we're talking you've been doing
this for a long time we're talking
crazy emotions around
your money and the privacy of that yeah
this is a threat to privacy that's what
this is you know it's it's like a a
banana republic where you can't trust
the banking system so you have to keep
your money under a mattress
and you have to stay off the grid
because you can't it's not trustworthy
they're correct why they steal the cheat
and you know some of these crazy
countries and if we're are we going to
devolve into that with this kind of
movement out of the federal government
of course the good news is we've got a
group of governors
on several of these issues that are
saying uh your overreach doesn't extend
across our state line
we're not going to allow it and then
we've got another group of governors
that went oh yeah we're all in uh
whatever you want to do
we're with you big joe
yeah this is out of control
out of control the tyranny is uh is real
so yeah just let them poke around in
everybody's bank account
not to mention how much that costs not
to mention how much you do but every
time you get ready to move your money
that you earned they want to know about
it
[Music]
uh
yeah we'll see how that works out
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 michael's with us in tampa
florida hey michael welcome to the
ramsey show
hey guys how you doing great man what's
up
hey so
um
i'm having trouble deciding if i need to
take um
this new job along with the challenges
the schedule would have with
me and my wife um
we just had like a big rent increase in
the entire tampa bay area
and the job
was pos was going to pay me probably
about eight grand more
walking into the door
and i wouldn't know if i should take the
job
why would you not take the job what are
you wondering about
um so
i have a older child
from a previous relationship
and she comes over
every other weekend
and it would disrupt
my time with her as well as my wife and
i are disagreeing about
you know i have one son
and um she wants him to play sports and
i do too but
by the games being on the weekend i
wouldn't be able to be there
and we've kind of been bickering back
and forth
about that
and i'm trying to get her to hold off
you know to agree to hold off on it but
i'm having a hard time yeah so are you
guys in tough shape financially to where
this eight thousand dollar bump is
really really needed
how is it going to affect you guys if
you don't take the bump
besides all the relationship stuff
i know that you guys recommend 25
um
our rent shouldn't be that
uh but i mean to take home pay and the
rent increase
will probably put it at about 30 percent
what do you make a year
combined last year we made 98.
okay
so you're talking about an eight percent
increase or seven percent increase
and
[Music]
your dispute is
you would be working every weekend
yes
doing what what are you going to be
doing
i'm a truck driver for dr pepper right
now and i have a better opportunity at a
food service distribution as a food
truck driver okay
and will you be working weekends then
the rest of your life
yeah because i have a friend of mine
that works there
and i was communicating with him about
it and i spoke with his direct
supervisor and he kept it
you know on he was honest with me he
said this he said he's been working
saturday for 18 years he says i hate it
you know and i just i have guys quit all
the time because they have kids that
want to
you know
play ball and they want to be there and
they can't
michael is it is it possible i just want
to know what your opinion is is it
possible do you think that you could
find another job making 8 000
even more than 8 000 more
where you don't have to work weekends
it's it's very tough um
i've tried tanker and hazmat because i
do have those endorsements on my license
but those guys work saturday and sunday
and evening time i've turned down
countless jobs even up to paying 90
grand because they want you to work in
the evening and it's saturday and sunday
are these all driving related jobs where
you're driving yes yeah but again i want
to put that question back to you i think
you've limited yourself
because you've got a background you may
enjoy driving i think you have to open
up your possibilities right here to say
well wait a second i've got some
experience and i've got some skill
and it's very transferable i can do a
whole lot more than just drive a truck
and you are making a pretty decent
household income together but you can
increase this i think you've got to open
yourself up to what's out there and when
you begin to look for those things you
will see those things and you got to get
busy on this because taking this job is
not about the 8 000 bump
you're gonna be very miserable
relationally because you're gonna miss
your kid you're gonna put pressure on
your wife to not let the kid play sports
and all that stuff and that's just a
bunch of relationship turmoil that is
related to you boxing yourself into this
is the only thing i can do
and i think that's the challenge and to
begin to see what else you can do
that is a much different schedule that
doesn't require you work weekends the
rest of your life this is a great market
right now to be looking
and you've got to just harness all of
that
negative energy and turn it into i'm
going to look for something else that
does
fit my relationship goals as well
because it's out there
yeah and this is the moment um because
with all the stuff happening in the
economy
one of the issues is logistics meaning
delivery by trucks
and uh we're you know we've got ships
that they can't get into port because
they can't get the trucks to put the
stuff on
and so
i'm not suggesting you start driving
over the road i'm just saying that truck
driving is at a premium right now
and so no i would not take this other
job but no i would not stay where i am
either that's correct and so i'm going
to do what ken said i'm going to expand
my uh the the color the page you're
coloring on is not big enough you need a
bigger page
and you need to draw a better picture of
where your future is going to be uh hang
on the line michael i would love to give
him a code a link and a code to the get
clear career assessment which is going
to help you see things you've never seen
before it's a wonderful tool take your
lesson 20 minutes it'll help you see
purpose in your work but more than that
give you some real possibilities you can
see what you have to offer to this world
because you've got a lot to offer
mark is in los angeles hey mark welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
dave i have a legacy journey question my
wife and i are on baby step seven and we
have a nest egg of about four million
three million in iras and one million in
a taxable brokerage account
we'll live off the interest you know
with the goal of preserving the nest egg
as an inheritance for my daughters
here's my question as we manage this
nest egg i'm currently planning to
deplete the money in the iras and grow
the money in the brokerage account over
time
with a goal of leaving the kids a
portfolio that's a 100 brokerage account
and no ira money
so their inheritance isn't encumbered
with any government strings or tax bonds
or anything and what i wondered was is
this the right strategy yes if so how
you would recommend i manage it to
achieve it yeah i mean you've got the
idea and it's just a matter of drawing
down on the thing
uh fast enough to keep
uh you know
that you hit the perfect mark right
where there's nothing left except the uh
brokerage account when you get to
retirement so
uh that your your money that you are
generous with while you're alive to
other things uh your money that you are
living off of all comes out of that ira
because that is it doesn't create an
inheritance tax the ira doesn't but it
is taxable because it's a traditional
ira it's going to be taxed uh as an
inherited ira or inherited 401k uh and
so yeah you're right you you you're on
the right track but there's not a magic
number to it if you know when you're
gonna die you can figure it out easy
yeah right but you know just start to
start running your numbers and
and deplete it exactly at that moment
but
you don't have to worry about that
if you can just minimize the damage or
minimize the process that they have to
screw with the government
by by using this strategy it's very very
wise i think you're way ahead of the
curve that's some really good thinking
on your part
really good thinking beautiful idea i
hadn't even thought of that actually
really no i haven't i may need to think
about that myself
well that's good that's kind of a nice
thing i've done a whole bunch of other
things to keep money off the estate plan
right uh from a state tax standpoint
but um but i haven't thought about that
stinking 401k which is sitting over
there it's a monster right so is it
about the pace by which he has to draw
it down there's no i mean well you've
got to use it up because anything he
doesn't use up is going to be taxed
right but you could there's nothing that
keeps you from pulling out of a certain
sums at some point and certain something
i mean you can do it discriminately
you're going to pay taxes on it he's
going to pay taxes on it or they're
going to pay taxes on it right you're
not going to get out of the taxes but
it's not a state tax it's income tax
right on the 401k
and um yeah this is one of those uh tax
dodges that the wealthy do
this is why the rs irs needs to get in
our bank account yeah this is exactly
evil because we you know we worked our
whole lives and we actually built up
something of our own money and already
paid taxes on it once and then they want
to get us again
pay your fair share you you full wealthy
people evil wealthy person you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage don and paula are with
us hey guys how are you good
where do you guys live let me dream
minnesota all right welcome to nashville
so good to have you how much debt have
you guys paid off
135 thousand dollars way to go and how
long did this take
oh 26 months good for you and your range
of income during that time
148 000 to 158 000. good what do you
guys do for a living uh i'm a physical
therapist i work for a large credit
union okay very cool what kind of debt
was the 135 000
uh we had three credit cards uh home
equity lot of credit
uh two vehicles a camper and a massive
student loan oh man
a big old student loan huh massive how
long you guys been married 18 years wow
so what happened two years ago that put
you on this ramsay journey
we actually heard about you back in 2007
a friend of us had given gifted us your
dvds
uh we read them listened to them thought
it was great at the time though we only
had the massive school loan the mortgage
so it just didn't stick
fast forward life happened and uh
you know i
paula paul always took care of the money
so in 2018 you know all of a sudden she
comes to me and says
you need to quit going out for lunch
well okay well thankfully i only live
seven minutes from lunch or from work
so i would go home and do dishes and
laundry and go back to work not a big
deal
so a few months go by and she uh
she says we need to cut cable we can't
afford it we can't afford 100 a month oh
okay well begrudgingly i did
so
um
in march of
2018 i'm working away and
that morning i get a i get a phone call
from her
she was traveling a lot for work and she
says you need to get out of this podcast
we need to do this now and it was your
podcast
hopped on never looked back
so we
we took our credit cards from april
and itemized everything
and uh in the month of march dave
we spent
uh 1 225 out in restaurants
and 225 out in coffee shops wow i never
know where your retirement was going you
were eating it never again no and we
never looked back wow it was game on
game over wow
wow yeah you don't do anything when he
jumps he jumps into the deep end
that's right
wow that's pretty impressive
very cool
so
you went wide open then for the next two
years yep game over these numbers are
pretty impressive i mean you've been on
beans and rice yup yes we have i mean
you had to have broke people making fun
of you
we had a lot of naysayers absolutely i
bet you did still a lot of haters yeah
unreal
and um
but now you're free and they're not so
here we go look at me now how you like
me now yeah
i like it yeah good for you guys i'm so
proud of you thank you very very well
done how's it feel to be free
unbelievable
it's
it is absolutely crazy
yeah i mean the emotion is all over you
done and it's powerful stuff
where's that coming from is it the
sacrifice is it the future is it all of
it together that you're feeling in this
moment well it's just
the feeling in 2019 you know
basically being normal living in an
outhouse and
now i'm in a penthouse
kitchen's college funded retirement
fully funded
it's done i don't have to worry about
money anymore it's over wow
very cool
wow so paula what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is now that
you guys did it
you know i think for me well a the
budget because it was crazy
you know always being in charge of the
finances and paying off the credit or
trying to pay off the credit cards and
we didn't have the money to pay off
their credit cards and and then we did a
budget and it's like holy crap we have
extra money to put toward this debt
where did this come from well it wasn't
going
out to eat and the coffee shops and so
the budget was huge but i think the
thing that made the difference in 2019
versus 07 when we initially heard about
you
was
we had a why you know in 07 we didn't
have the kids we didn't have to worry
about college
and now we have the kids and we
have a lake lot and the goal was to
build a house at the lake lot and
be able to do that when our kids are
still with us and not out of the house
and so i think it's having the budget
but having that big why
so it sounds like you were handling the
money obviously right and just kind of
giving don instructions
and uh the last instruction you gave him
was uh listen to this podcast which
meant that you no longer got to handle
the money by yourself but you also
didn't have all the weight on your own
shoulders
carrying all the decisions by yourself
and
talk about how important it is or how
you felt when your husband has put his
shoulder up under there and lifted
some of the weight off of you by making
the decisions together
it was it was huge i mean i was the one
that always took care of everything and
all of a sudden don is the one that's
checking the bank account like
500 times a day you lit him on fire
didn't you and he's like oh just so you
know i updated the budget i updated
every dollar um and it's huge and and
honestly it's so nice because
i know that we're both on the same page
you know because back in the day there
were times where we would go out to eat
and he'd be like oh
you know i got this and i'd look at him
like uh we don't we don't got the money
to got this
now i don't need to worry
yeah so great
all right so so
don you got on board right and it's
obviously went all in okay absolutely
what was the most extreme thing you did
early on that you look back on now and
you go this this helped me go from
conviction and knowing that we have to
do it to this got me really going
um
you know there was
an instance a couple weeks in where she
had called me and
she was down uh
shopping with one of her sisters and
she had asked me she could buy a
sweatshirt and i said no you cannot buy
a sweatshirt you can use one of my
sweatshirts i have 12 of them that i
never wear
so you can go ahead and use one of mine
if you need a sweatshirt we do not need
a sweatshirt wow the bravery to say that
my man how did that go i want to hear
the rest of that story well i told i was
shopping with my sister she was in town
and she's like oh paula this is really
cute you've got to get this and i was
like no that's that's not in the budget
and she's like oh come on paula it is a
sweatshirt and i was like
i can't it's not in the budget and she
said fine i'll call up dawn i'll ask don
and i said oh oh this is called you can
ask don i know what he's gonna tell you
he's gonna tell you no way and she's
like he is not and she got off the phone
and she goes don told me you couldn't
get the sweatshirt i was like i told you
he was gonna say no
nice
that's discipline though no that's it
that's when listen if you live like no
one else later you can live like no one
else yeah and you know when you make 158
000 a year and you don't have any debt
you can get a sweatshirt yeah by the way
i would like to point out at this
appropriate time don you should probably
buy her a sweatshirt yeah
one that one that says nashville on it
while you're here she's earned it this
woman earned a sweatshirt
we're we're gonna we're gonna go all in
on that i think so matter of fact ken's
gonna buy you don't there it is
hey why not
with my money
you guys are fun thank you so much
congratulations we're very very proud of
you you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages let's get them
up into the shot
we have garrett and owen who are 12. and
mallory who is 10. all right very very
good most awesome very cool we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's a your next chapter in your story
for sure you've changed your whole
legacy guys as you said you've got a
great why uh you changed your life for
your kids and you changed their life in
the process very cool stuff also copy
the total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody one of those people
that was making fun of you maybe maybe
maybe we can help them out that's a good
idea so very well done all right don and
paula garrett owen and mallory from
minnesota
135
000 paid off in 26 months making 148 to
158 you are looking at life change right
in front of you count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done right there baby
yeah freedom
[Laughter]
it doesn't get any better
hey listen when you work that hard and
you sacrifice that deep you'll never go
back no people never go back i'm not
going to talk to them later they go well
dave you know we sort of fell off and
went and bought a car on a jet you're
not going to hear that from don no don
has changed he's done yes he is he's
stick a fork in him he's done yes this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
two two 825-5225 brian is with us in
boulder colorado hey brian how are you
hey dave good how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
well pleasure to be speaking with you um
i wanted to talk to you about uh we
recently refinanced our home to a
15-year mortgage
um but it puts us over
your recommended 25
of our take-home pay it puts us more
like 35
and
just wondering if we should be looking
for
a
cheaper home
well here's the thing the whole reason
for that ratio
of 25 is for people not to sign up for
something that causes them
to be so pinched in their budget that
they're tempted to go into debt for
things they should have been saving up
for
in other words if the house payment is
pinching your budget so tight that every
little thing that comes up looks like
it's going to be a new debt then that's
being house poor
and that that's the thing so 35 doesn't
kill you particularly if you are
on a career path where you're going to
see your income come up and it's not
going to be 35 percent long for long
it's going to be 30
and then later on it's gonna be 25 so i
don't know that we have to panic about
this but it's it's just a matter of
don't do not be continuously engaging in
a process that that makes you broke
that makes your monthly cash flow
pinched and so you know as long as you
have a good career path and you think
you're going to see your income coming
up i wouldn't panic and jump ship on it
uh at this stage now if you're going to
go buy a home
don't do that
okay don't don't go buy a home and take
on 35 gold well my income's going to go
up that's just that's you know that's
twisting my words that's not what i'm
saying but you're already in a house are
we going to sell the house move go
through all that expense when in 24 or
36 months your ratios would have been
all right anyway because your income
came up no i'm not going to do that
but don't go signing up for these things
in the future that put you in a pinch
that's the whole point of the thing
so ken the great resignation is underway
a lot of people 55 percent of americans
one survey says are thinking about
changing jobs actively right now
couldn't be a better time for us to
launch a book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to getting work you love
i think your books timing might be just
uh maybe the best i've ever seen
yeah we we believe so because people are
changing for a variety of reasons so
whether or not you just want to get
promoted make more money you're doing
what you really enjoy now you just want
to move up get a bigger shovel to get
through the baby steps or
you're just showing up to a nine to five
and you feel like you're just miserable
when you pull up in the parking lot
monday morning
or you just want to find what is that
meaningful work this book really helps
everybody who wants to work on purpose
who wants more than a j-o-b who wants to
make income and impact and the seven
stages that we unpack in the book no
matter who you are where you are will
get you there and that's why we're so
excited about it everybody knows that
there's something they're supposed to do
but they just wonder how do i get there
is it possible and the answer is yes
there is a clear path yeah just a couple
weeks before we ship these books or in
pre-sale right now if you want a hundred
dollars worth of extra items including
the e-book including the um the uh audio
book including a whole bunch of other
things go ahead and get the book now for
20
and you get over a hundred dollars worth
of bonus tools resume templates and
guides a video course that'll coach you
through the interview process all of
this paycheck from paycheck to purpose
at ramsey solutions go ahead and
pre-order it now our question today
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings with free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run all
the time you will uh well you save even
more use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from ahmet in
michigan i'm 30 years old i work for a
local credit union and we get quarterly
reviews i've met expectation for my next
review and i've upped my skill set i
want to ask for a sizable raise
after working really hard during the
lockdown where half of my team worked
remotely during that time one co-worker
and i have been in the office whenever
it was open and i recently found out
that one of my co-workers is making 15
to 17 000 more than me and when this
person takes time off i'm responsible
for making sure their tasks get done the
only person who knows how much i work
uh how much work i put in is my manager
i currently work over 60 hours a week i
do love my job in the company i'm
working for but it is hard when i know
i'm putting in more work than everyone
else and getting paid less well we've
heard this question before and
unfortunately this the psychology around
this kind of information that you've
gotten is really hard to overcome
because you are now aware and you are
comparing yourself and that is a very
dangerous dangerous place to be in
because you can't do much about this in
this situation when you go into your
next review uh you know
leveraging this information isn't going
to help you i wouldn't do it what i
would talk about is a growth plan i
would lay out
how much you love the company as you as
you put in this email and that you want
to be here and you want to grow not just
professionally but financially but you
lead with professional growth what are
some areas that i can get better in
where i'm a little bit weak what are
some skills some tools i can add to my
tool belt
that will allow me to a get more
responsibility drive greater value b and
then c grow financially as well that's
the posture by which you approach this
so that your leaders get some buy-in
they see your hunger but also your
humility and that's all you can do and
if you've got healthy leadership they're
going to respond and they're going to
talk about a growth plan and then
measure the growth that's tied to
compensation if they are not going to
address this and they kick the can down
the road this is a sign
that it may be time for you to move on
and where you see a ladder and not a lid
yeah that's the thing and so there is
nothing wrong with saying
in my mind and you can correct me ken um
how can i add value that will make you
want to give me more money because i'd
like to see some more income but i want
i want to be worth it yes
instead of i deserve this because so and
so that's right if you say i did i
deserve this because 60 hours i deserve
this because so and so you know the
entitlement i deserve this thing
um is uh one of the most negative
possible emotions
uh that you can that you can generate
and you've gotten yourself kind of down
in that hole a little bit here yeah a
little bit of a pity party going on in
the email there oh sure and uh and
rightly so but still
you know
it's a wrong posture for you to get
ahead you're not supposed to know what
your co-worker makes
and this is why
because it's almost impossible to not
deal positively with that and that's why
i laid it out when you sit with your
leader you don't ask for a raise you ask
for a growth plan you lead with as you
notice what i said first where can i get
better what are some areas where you
where you think i can how can i add
value that once makes you want to give
me if some i'm not i mean i own ramsey
solutions if you come in my office and
i'm doing a review with you or whatever
or we're talking or even you just came
in randomly and said listen
i i'd like to make more money and
uh the way i want to do that is i want
to be worth more how can i be worth more
how can i add value versus i actually
had a guy come in my office many years
ago had more degrees than a thermometer
overeducated fool
and said uh you know
show me his resume you know a guy like
me that has this many degrees
we usually make like a lot more than i
make now
and i said well you know you're working
a small business son and he said what do
you mean i said well small business
works like this your raise is effective
when you are
i don't give a crap about your degrees
when you do something i'll share it with
you
that's how it works in a small business
but but you know i got a degree so i got
or i got six degrees so you know what
are you a black belt yeah i mean come on
no
so um that didn't that doesn't that
didn't play in dave's office no and it
won't play anybody else's either by the
way exactly right not because i'm a jerk
it's just that's the way it is yeah open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five again this is launch
day for the new documentary
borrowed future is available any great
doc where any great documentaries are
seen
for instance you can see it on apple tv
you can rent it for 4.99 on any of these
locations including app google play
uh apple tv uh
amazon prime thank you there i know
there's another one yeah i gotta decide
which one i'm gonna watch it maybe i'll
just do all three of them well we're
number two right now we launched it this
morning yes we're number two among
documentaries on apple right now that's
great so it's already coming out of the
gate pretty strong and i got to tell you
when you guys watch this thing you're
going to tell everybody you know they
have to watch it it is amazing yeah so
proud of our team borrowed future how
student loans are killing the american
dream out today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality host of the
ken coleman show where he talks about
careers and jobs in author of the number
one best-selling book the proximity
principle and the new book from paycheck
to purpose he is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five samantha is with us in
san francisco hi samantha how are you
hi i'm doing good how are you today
better than we deserve what's up
um well i wanted to ask you guys
especially at ken about
possibly
giving me some direction on where i
should go
career-wise at this point i currently am
in an electrical apprenticeship it's
actually the family trade a bunch of
electricians but
i'm starting to realize that it's not
really for me i'm a single mom and so
there's a lot of pressure when it comes
to trying to balance that as well as
balance
this career as well it just
seems as though i keep having these
roadblocks you know put in front of me
and so it doesn't seem like i'm going
down the right path and because i'm
starting to feel that way i've been
thinking about some other career options
that might be good for me and i just
want to make sure that if i do change
careers that i do go down on the right
path instead of you know walking down
another path and realizing that it's not
for me again sure
uh what what's the big idea there is
there a leading idea in the clubhouse
right now
yeah well i mean i have two two ideas um
one of them is actually
your idea i was thinking about being
that i'm here in the silicon valley area
going to betheltech and trying to get
a certification with them to become a ux
designer because there's a lot of open
jobs for that here
so that was one option and then if if
nothing else mattered and i followed my
heart it would be i would try to go do
producing um i really like the idea of
that i did a lot of stage management in
high school so i did a lot of the live
production type management and
background back behind the scenes type
of
work and you know i really do love that
kind of work but i understand that that
would take me getting a little bit more
qualified in the professional setting
before i could actually make that a
career yeah what does that look like
just fast forward real quick
take me up the ladder i have a good idea
of that industry but you've got a better
idea what would that look like if
everything was just equal and we could
fast forward you there you're making the
money you want to make what would you be
doing where would you be doing it
yeah i mean i i love the idea of you
know the producing live events um i
thought a lot about doing professional
stage management for a long time but i
don't think that the purpose would
really be behind professional stage
management i'm in live theater so i was
thinking more like live events that help
people you know okay talk shows and that
kind of deal okay so i'm glad you gave
me that specific i want to encourage you
on something there is a path to get to
that um and i will tell you that uh
you're already qualified to do that you
know the fact that you've done some
production work in the background uh i
mean excuse me in your background your
career background
you are uh qualified now if you've got
the talent of organization and detail
management you've got some good personal
skills and connecting with people
and you're a good coordinator is the
word that's coming to mind you can do
that and you can get in if you do a
great job you can do well in fact i've
got a friend who lives in the nashville
area who now he's been doing this 25
years who now gets called for just every
la award show that you can imagine i see
him on tv all the time he's a
professional stage manager now that's
more you know that's very cool yeah so i
just want to share with you that that's
possible okay
so now it's about i'm a single mom i
want to get out of this trade that's not
right being an electrician that's kind
of not my jam i'm thinking about
technology
as a ux designer i got to tell you i
like the idea of you moving into a good
solid day job
okay that takes care of you and the
child or the children and we got some
great stability and then you begin to
work
uh live events
on the side that's going to be some
weekends maybe a little bit of travel
but if you can travel some and get in
that live event industry and as a
contractor and we at ramsey solutions
hire
some not many but some live event
producers you can get in that way and
begin to build it and with that
technology background and degree and
qualification
i think it gives you i think it's both
and i think that'll be a really nice
stable path because you're going to have
to build relationships over time and get
in and then once you realize i'm in and
i can make the income i need
then i step into that so i think you've
got either or uh if you can make the
connections now
and get in the live event space and make
what you need to make i'd say go now if
you need to build up to that
then i would look at technologies a very
safe day job
brian is in jonesboro arkansas hey brian
welcome to the ramsey show
hey ken it's an honor to talk to you you
too
i've always had a low self-esteem and i
recently went through a separation and
divorced
how do i
throw my net worth without confusing it
with self-worth
well let me reverse that
who
builds a big net worth and what type of
person builds a big net worth and
confuses it
with self-worth
not sure
i would
someone with a low self-esteem
no no not at all no because low
self-esteem is not you know you don't
confuse network if you have a high net
worth and a low self-esteem you're not
you're not confusing it
so that's not the case the person that
becomes what we're saying is someone
becomes wealthy and they become a jerk
or they become power hungry or they
become they think they're all that and
so what they are is they're spiritually
and emotionally psychologically shallow
they have no spiritual depth to their
life
they have no psychological depth to
their life and let me help you with this
a person who asks this question
is not prone to that
yeah the person i'm talking about would
never ask this question
they would never go i'm confusing my net
worth with my self-worth i'm really i'm
all that because i've got a million
dollars you know that's that's that's
somebody that made that confusion and
that's a shallow entitled little jerk
you know
and whether they're a 58 year old little
jerk or 18 you're a little jerk but um
you're not going to have that problem
brian i i just hear failure all over you
yeah you've been through such help
sounds like some tough stuff and you're
starting to question how valuable you
are and so i think i'm going to give you
two practical answers to your question
number one
you need to get around some people who
know you really well
who can remind you
of how valuable you are to them
secondly i want you to just do a little
self exercise and just begin to get to
know brian again and ask yourself what
do i do really well what have people
complimented me on in my life i think i
messed that up
i think he was saying i've got a low net
worth so i think i have a low self-worth
he is he's he's i was flipping it i went
the other way well i was going where
you're going
he's struggling financially and in his
relationships and he's going i'm having
a hard time seeing if i'm valuable
because i don't have any money yeah okay
well your value is intrinsic your value
as a person your value as a human has
nothing to do with your money that's
right but that's just uh that's a normal
transaction when you've gotten the crap
beat out of you like you have with the
loss of relationships and everything
else so one other question i'm sorry i
completely blew that no it's okay but
brian here's what i want you to
apologize into you oh i know
but i'm just saying it's okay but brian
here's what i want you to do i want you
to find some people to add value to
volunteer go love on somebody go do
something valuable for somebody
and feel the value that you be of help
to someone serve and that will raise
your
self-worth and it is independent of your
net worth i'm so sorry i messed that up
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage jimmy's with us hi jimmy
how are you dave i'm great how are you
better than i deserve sir so where do
you live white plains new york white
plains all right very cool welcome to
nashville and uh how much debt have you
paid off jimmy i've paid off just over
97 000
very cool how long did that take you sir
just about five years
love it
and uh your range of income during that
time talking about pay after tax um 53
to start and finishing up at 78. good
for you what do you do for a living i am
a training specialist i work for a large
engineering company um so if your
employees here at ramsay have to take
any of those computerized e-learning
modules i make those for the company
that i work for ah okay good for you
very cool what kind of debt was your 97
000 it was a car and two student loans
one private one federal ah
okay
so what put you on this ramsey journey
thing five years ago so in my family any
time you have a question about money my
cousin stephen he's a little older to me
he's in his 50s
he's the guy you talk to about money
quick background on him he's in his
early 50s owns a mini mansion in north
carolina free and clear is retired
already after putting two kids through
college so that's who you want to be
when you grow up gotcha i had a question
for you because of steve yeah cousin
steve
so i had a question for him something
about my 401k back when i was new with
my current company so i called him and i
was asking him whatever it was that i
had to ask him about the 401k and he
goes hold on time out stop for a minute
let's take a step back you just finished
your masters right yes steve okay how
much student loan debt do you have
hanging out i told him the
embarrassingly high number of student
loan debt that i had and he goes all
right have you heard of dave ramsey and
i said
actually yes and the reason that i have
was because my mother actually had the
exact copy of total money makeover that
i brought with me here today sitting on
her coffee table at her house it's a
great coaster it really it really was i
think i used it a few times myself
before before i realized what exactly it
was so my apologies for that that's it's
all good it's it's america's greatest
coaster
so anyway so he goes read that book and
then
talk to me later and we'll see how you
doing i read that book
and it literally completely changed my
life and i'm not just saying that to
blow smoke dave really i never thought
about money the same way again wow i
like cousin steve yeah yeah he's my
greatest promo guy way to go steve
that's cool he kind of handled it like i
think you would he was like hold on
let's just go back he just cut him off
and said no no no no no no no no no no
i'm doing it i'm going to talk to you
about your 401k until you read your
mother's coaster that's right i love him
to get the coaster off the coffee table
and i don't think we even finished the
conversation about the 401k from there
on out it was all about the debt yeah
just all and you got done you got done
and five years later here you sit all of
it's gone car
student loans everything sitting with a
master's degree your mattresses and what
industrial and organizational psychology
which he uses every day yes he does
fabulous yeah and thus you and thus you
are doing that that's beautiful i like
it very cool very cool jimmy i love it
how's it feel to be free oh it's
tremendous dave it's like having a 400
pound monkey no longer on your back
absolutely absolutely what do you tell
people you're a trainer what's the key
to getting out of debt ignore and drown
out all the noise as you're going
through this process i mean i live in
new york i meet a lot of people that
wear very expensive suits and sound like
they really know what they're talking
about when it comes to money i've had
people try to get me into cryptocurrency
people try to get me into pyramid
schemes i mean all kinds of things that
we're going to take away from my total
money makeover debt-free journey
and sometimes they make points that like
make sense for a second and then you're
like wait a minute no i listen to dave
ramsey that's what i'm gonna do so it's
drowning out all that noise staying the
course and really just being focused on
it wow submitting to the plan exactly
and stick to the plan stick to the plan
stick to the plan good for you very well
done sir wow this is powerful it is i
i'm curious is there a moment you can
look back to or you you said okay i i
caught some serious momentum uh or did
you just from day one you were a bull
and you never let up
the momentum and this is where i think
the snowball method is really really
effective it was i had one of the
student loans was for 3 000 so that was
easy cash then came the car i had i
think 11 000 left on the car at that
point once i paid off the car and now i
had 280 from the car plus 30 for that
other one 330 which for me back then was
a lot of money at the time now that i
had that free to apply towards the
largest debt which was the largest
student loan that was the point where it
was like all right now i'm really making
progress now we're really going to see
this thing take off awesome
wow how big how important is that to
experience that momentum in this journey
it's essential because if you don't feel
it if you don't feel it here your head
is not going to listen to what's in here
if what's in here is not there if that
makes sense does that make sense man
you're preaching that somebody ought to
tweet that that's phenomenal what you
just said that's really good very well
done very well done congratulations jim
i'm proud of you thank you dave and ken
proud of cousin steve
oh he'll be so happy because i'm going
to show him the clip once this edge so
he'll be that's awesome he'll laugh for
sure i love it was he one of your
cheerleaders as you went through this
absolutely he was of course my my family
mother father sister they were all very
supportive but who i really have to
thank is the ramsey community because
they were my accountability partners i
mean if you notice i'm standing up here
all by myself i don't have a spouse i
don't have kids there was nobody to
really hold me accountable for doing all
this per se but when i turned on youtube
three four times a week to watch the
replay from the show just hearing the
phone calls and and
seeing the reactions and the emotion
from people when they did their screams
and just hearing all their stories
that's what kind of held me accountable
so i did this not only for myself but
kind of also as what i felt was an
obligation to the ramsey community so a
thank you to the entire ramsey community
of listeners seriously from my heart to
yours i love it
love this guy this is great what a what
a powerful thing we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you
a new coaster for your mom's table and
uh a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away so that can be a
coaster on someone else's table hey but
it hangs out long enough eventually it
gets red i'm i'm going with this plan
multi-purpose it's a long play it's not
a short game it's a long game play but
i'm going with it it's working for me
well done jimmy very well done all right
jimmy from yonkers new york 97 000 paid
off in five years making
53-78 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three
two
one i'm debt free
i love it
that is so fun
uh
i think that whole segment was tweetable
oh i know i mean that that screen right
i want to tackle somebody and i don't
tackle anybody but i want
he's ready to go i mean the sheer
passion from this guy how about the
shout out to the entire community and i
think that's a really interesting point
that there's a whole bunch of people
that we get the privilege to serve
and and in serving them
they end up encouraging each other it
really is the community it it's it's
amazing you know all the people in
ramsey plus and all the people have come
to the events all the years all the
people that are on the facebook page all
it's amazing
to see that here's a single guy who
shouted out all the other people he came
in contact with on the same journey yep
that's really cool and there's that um
well it gives you permission
to do stuff that that the rest of the
culture is not doing
when you look around you go okay there's
there's about a bazillion other smart
people doing what i'm doing exactly
right
and yes there's a bunch of crazies out
there in the toxic culture but um but
but but but there isn't this oasis of
humans that are engaged in
transformation they're engaged in doing
the work the hard work of change that's
right and changing is hard
wow get yourself a community even if
it's on the facebook page uh or on the
youtube channel get in community it's uh
it's vital way to go jimmy yeah proud of
you man good stuff way to go cousin
steve
i love it love it love it love it
everybody needs a cousin steve most
people don't have one though
that's a privilege right there i feel
like we should get cousin steve on the
line james i mean wouldn't that guy be a
great interview at some point
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage
blake and macy are with us hey guys how
are you we're good how are you better
than we deserve where do you live
uh we live in dallas texas all right
welcome to nashville and all the way up
here to do a debt free scream how much
have you paid off we have paid off 66
147
cool how long did that take about 15
months good for you and your range of
income during that time so we started
out at 133 000 and then at the end of
the 15 it was a 143 000. cool what do
y'all do for a living uh i'm a
mechanical engineer and then i'm an
escrow officer
you're a what an escrow officer oh okay
cool great very good what kind of debt
was this 66 000 uh it was about at four
credit cards uh with that we
financed our wedding our honeymoon uh
just
about everything uh yeah you name it we
put it on a credit card a really
expensive couch and uh in both of our
cars also so it was four credit cards
and two cars so you're just kind of
normal yeah we were really normal so you
come home from the expensive wedding
honeymoon and expensive cars are sitting
in the driveway how long have you been
married uh almost four years okay so
you've been married a couple years and
you look up and say
uh we got to do something different what
what introduced you to ramsey how did
you get this stuff going so my sister
and brother-in-law actually had paid off
a lot of
over 175 000 a couple years ago and it
was thanksgiving of 2019 and we just
found out we were pregnant and so um and
i just talking to her you know at casual
thanksgiving dinner and i was just
kind of like well we we have all this
debt and we don't really know what to
what to do but we i just i showed an
interest in wanting to pay it off and so
she just very gently mentioned you and
that your podcast and she was just like
this is easy to listen to
you know on the way to work or while
you're working out or whatever and so
the very next day on our drive home um
we listened to our first podcast and
something just clicked to blake has he
was the nerd i'm the free spirit and he
has always been good with money he tried
to put us put us on a budget right when
we first got married and i laughed and
um i was just like no
but
uh no
but after listening i don't know it was
just something about it was just easy to
listen to you and just kind of get what
we needed to you know to get going and
then um it clicked and so that was
thanksgiving and so january of 2020 we
started executing our plan we're like
okay this is what we're going to do you
know the the baby steps everything they
my same sister and brother-in-law gifted
us the total money mocha money makeover
and so we read that and you know like a
week and then we were pretty gung-ho and
then covet happened a couple months
later i was pregnant um and we were very
lucky that we kept our jobs and um you
know we didn't have to lose any income
so that was a blessing but um so covet
actually helped us because we didn't do
anything we weren't going anywhere
and i was pregnant so it was like we
weren't really going to go out and do
anything anyways and so um that it made
it was initially a two-year goal and we
ended up doing it in 15 months wow you
blew through it yeah yeah and it was
just it was all the the debt snowballs
it's just it works it gave us all the
momentum in the world so what was uh
maybe one of the most radical kind of
get after it intense things you guys did
in this journey so i think uh one of the
things was uh saying no to everything so
like it was so hard that you know we're
sitting there and all our friends are
going to beautiful trips and everything
or they're wanting to go to dinner or
anything and we were just having like no
i'm sorry we can't and
it was just hard the fear of missing out
type thing but once we got over that and
then i think the probably the one of the
things was we were expecting our first
child and so i wanted to go crazy with
the nursery and and doing all the things
you know that a mom wants to with their
first kid and well that's unusual
no one ever does that yeah and we didn't
have any money because we were paying
off all this debt and so we didn't buy
one piece of furniture for the nursery
we it was everything was given to us or
hand-me-downs or i mean we just we
didn't have to go use any of our money
for our snowball and it turns out
two-month-olds aren't that picky about
where they sleep right yeah right so
that was that i think that was probably
one of the hardest yeah that's hard
that's a big deal yeah it's a big deal
not decorating the nursery except with
uh things that folks give you that's a
big deal yeah and it i like i like it a
lot but it's a big deal
yeah very cool good for you guys well
you just proved the difference in a need
and a what the kid needs a place to
sleep a want is everything you want
around them they don't even know what's
there
right it's all about it's all about mom
making a nest and dad making a nest or
dad making momma nest or however that
works but yeah it's uh it's real yeah so
absolutely
and people spend an
amazing amount of money on that stuff
yeah and the baby literally does not
care at all not even a little bit not
even a little bit yeah so way to go you
guys all right what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is uh one
of the things that i think is uh
communication and collaboration but uh
the main thing was the the budget and i
think that every dollar app was just
mind-blowing for us and we sat down
every month and at the beginning of it
you know we assessed what we could do
and then you know at the end of it it
was easy to say no when it was the
category was zero it's sorry and then
and then i would just say going into it
knowing that you know mentally it's a
short-term sacrifice for a long-term
reward i mean if you go into it thinking
oh this is going to be a bree i mean
nobody really thinks it's going to be a
breeze but if you think that it's going
to be easier than it really is
then i think people get stuck a few
months in and they get frustrated and
they're you know they just give up and i
think we very really we just sat down
every month and was just like this is
our goal this is what we want to do and
15 months is literally nothing in the
grand scheme of things and so
and i mean i'm so glad we did that it's
just it's been it's an amazing feeling
especially now having the baby he's 15
months old now and um
it's just it's a it's a whole new world
i could i can't imagine uh still having
that much debt and also taking care of
you know
a baby absolutely yeah absolutely well
congratulations thank you who were your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you
definitely my sister and brother-in-law
that got us on we got started every time
we paid off a credit card we'd send them
a screenshot
yeah i like it they celebrated us
through and through and then my parents
and blake's parents and just yeah and
even like our friends and coworkers like
everyone was super supportive they
really were cool loved the journey for
us that's cool so who all came on the
trip with you
my parents and um our baby is over there
yeah okay all right cool all right your
baby's name is what asher now do you
want asher in the shot for this or yeah
yeah we'll make it all right cool
very cool good good good we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you that
is the next chapter in your story for
sure you've changed your family tree way
to go you guys excellent job and a copy
of the total money makeover for you to
give away when someone at thanksgiving
mentions that they need some help you'll
have a book you can hand them very good
stuff blake and macy and asher asher's
life has been changed by his mom and dad
dallas texas 66 000 paid off in 15
months making 133 to 143 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
i love
it i love it
well at the break we're going to
interview asher about the psychological
damage of having been brought home from
the hospital into a used baby bed yeah
you can just see the little guy scarred
right there he looks like he's struggled
yeah he looks and it looks like it's you
know the wallpaper on the wall was not
right in that nursery i'm just saying
there's there's a permanent damage done
here didn't have a branch those parents
should be assuming what do they call
those things that like
thank you dave
dave's got all the baby stuff dialed in
now yeah including the expense of
nurseries although i didn't write a
single check for any of them but um i am
privy to the process all of them i've
toured all of them at lengths at various
times of day and and even into the
evenings yes it has happened so yeah
that's it's uh
but i i hey same thing happened when the
ramsey kids were coming home a million
years ago or the coleman kids you gotta
have a gotta have a special room gotta
have a special thing but we in america
go nuts what we spend on our pets
would support egypt oh
don't even get me started on that one i
love my pets and you love yours too
but man oh man what we spend on
halloween
what americans spend on halloween
would do away from with hunger for most
of the people in america that have
hunger issues
by the way the kids these days dave are
getting full-sized candy bars i grew up
in their old days when we got a little
tiny little one
half of a bite well that's what's wrong
with the world this is just saying it's
just a spool it's just awful it's just
awful
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well you're hearing all these debt-free
screams and you're thinking about fall
stuff you got to buy like halloween
candy and jackets and sweaters christmas
is coming up christmas sneaks up on
people every year like they move it or
something it's always in december i'll
just put christmas on a credit card
again what do you think you are in
congress
hey when you plan ahead with a budget
you can keep christmas from getting out
of control and the best way to do that
is with our world-class budgeting tool
every dollar
and you can sync up with that and go
through financial peace university at
ramsey plus with a ramsey plus
membership and every dollar working
along with financial peace university
inside ramsey plus gives you everything
you want stress free
you can get control you can be the these
people you were just listening to start
budgeting with every dollar by texting
budget to 33
789
text budget to 33789
dan is with us in hudson wisconsin hey
dan welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thank you how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
i just want to give you and ken and your
team a huge shout out my wife and i
recently became 100 percent debt-free
here we go everything so
we are super grateful for all you and
your team do
uh my question
tonight on baby step seven
part of what we're doing we're
self-employed we have a small business
is to up the contributions for our
iras for our employees
we currently have a simple ira we're
matching three percent
and
i was told that three percent of the max
that we can do in a simple ira that's
true um
okay and then
would it be worth going into a 401k and
i was how many employees do you have
we have six
uh
talk with your smartvestor pro
about this the simple ira is a 401k for
small business but it is very
um structured it requires that you put
in three percent no more no less
as a match and it's 100 vested from day
one for anybody that goes in
uh the 401k could cost you as much as
five or ten thousand dollars a year in
administrative fees and across five or
six employees that seems like a waste
um
so it might be the way to do this is
with a sep
ira you can do that in addition to
the simple ira the sep
plan the simplified employee pension
plan
says any employee that's been with you
three more than three of the last five
years you are required to put into that
the same percentage of your income that
you put in for you
that's why a lot of people don't use it
so it works really good for a
solopreneur
like if i want to just dump a bunch of
money into retirement plan but if i've
got employees been with me more than
three the last five years and i put in
15 of my income i have to put in 15 of
their income for them
and so you're wanting to do that so this
might work really well for you you know
you're not required to put in any amount
but and you can change it year to year
so you could come up on the end of the
year and go hey this year i'm going to
put in seven percent of my income and
i'm putting in seven percent of
everybody else's in addition to doing
the simple
okay and so you the good news about it
is it would give you flexibility you
don't have to do anything
uh depending on how your profits go that
year and you could decide
you know you could do a little bit
through the year and then pop it up at
the end
and you know jack the numbers up at the
end of the year if you wanted to so
check with your smartvestor pro uh if
you're not working with one go to
ramseysolutions.com and click smart
investor those are the people we
recommend in the investment world it'll
drop down a list of the ones in your
area you can pick one from that list and
they'll all be people that we have
vetted and people that have the heart of
a teacher very cool when a guy has six
employees and wants to make sure he's
taking care of their retirement
brings up the old phrase dave you said a
billion times if you live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else and this is the backbone of
america right here there's a young man
they've done the hard work they've
they've become debt free now he wants to
pour into his employees
i mean that's phenomenal yeah that right
there no one requiring no he's calling
and asking yeah that was passed it was
not a a an executive order no
it was not the irs looking into his bank
account no
it wasn't any of that stuff it was just
a guy who did well and thought you know
i want to share with the team
that helped me get here yeah and um
knowing that they could leave and take
that money with them yeah they can at
any time that's the rule
but uh what a great heart i love that
yes robert is with us in california hey
robert welcome to the ramsey show
hello um
yeah so my question is very related to
ken's book that he's been working on and
basically i have two job offers
both really good offers but one of them
is substantially higher than the other
and
the one that's higher is working for a
really big tech corporation
that i wouldn't necessarily be super
excited about
and the one that's lower is a job i'd be
much more excited about but it's a lot
lower it's like uh 70 000 left so i'm
wondering what you what are the two
numbers
uh it's like
240 total compensation versus 170
doing what
software development for the tech
corporation what's the other option
240 and 170.
yeah but what's the what kind is it both
tech jobs tech development yeah they're
both software which one's a big company
yeah they're both
software development but the the smaller
uh the lower one of the smaller company
that's doing work that i think is
actually interesting where i would be
much more excited to like go to my job
every day as opposed to
exactly all right so let's ask this
question for that company
you're more excited is there a ladder
what does it look like a year two three
years down the line if you take the 170
doing the work that you're interested in
so they've definitely assured me that
there's a ladder but it's a little
harder to find information on how much
of a ladder there is because the
companies the the lower salary one that
i'm more excited about is only a year
and a half old as a company so there's
not a lot of information on how the
ladder's been for other people yeah
what do you make currently you've got
two offers what are you currently making
i currently make about 130. so they're
both they're both
increases obviously one's a huge
increase so yeah let me ask you this if
if both of them were the same pay which
one would you choose
oh i would definitely choose the smaller
company by far if they're the same thing
so to me though this is the advice i
give dave may disagree and he wouldn't
be wrong but i have talked to enough
people on the ken coleman show and the
ramsay show that have taken the
promotion or taken an offer that was
more money
and they'll call me back and they'll say
i took it
and i'm miserable now or i don't have
the meaning i wish i was doing the other
work and i think that you've got to
remove the money from the equation
because you're not going backwards on
either and you've got to say what is it
that i want to do why do i enjoy option
two
more than option one and if there is a
ladder it seems that there is i'm always
going to say
follow your heart and do the work that
you're excited about if there is a
ladder and it sounds like there so
that's where i would go because i think
money's not enough to sustain you
completely agree only i'm going to do a
modified option one i'm going to go back
in and go guys
my heart is here this is what i want to
do i love what you're doing i want to be
plugged in i got this other offer for
240.
help me help me figure out a way to come
here
yeah so i mean they probably they're not
going to go to 240. i didn't say that
i didn't say you had to match it i just
said help me figure out a way to come
here
and then they you know and it could it
could be that they very clearly outline
a detailed ladder on a calendar yes it
could be that they offer you stock
options in this startup that are worth a
whole heck of a lot more than 70.
right that's true they could give you
some points in the deal what the stock
is going to be worth you take you a
couple deal points and and you take this
job yeah but you go back in and you ju
you just smile and you just say i really
want to come here help me figure out a
way
right that's a great point and then just
let them squirm and start answering that
question that don't you don't tell them
what the answer is
and here's what's going to happen a
they're going to give you a more more
than 170. b they're going to offer a
ladder or something like that and c they
may even offer you points in the deal
and none of those are on the table today
and one simple question shut up
let this let the let the pressure fall
in the room on the other side of the
table
gently kindly say
i really want to come here these other
people are offering me 240. help me
figure out a way to come
and i promise you it will not result in
anything but more money in this
conversation it's a wonderful
negotiating tool it'll work for it'll
just just hey man that phone call's
worth 20 grand shut up and this show's
free
there you go
you don't get this anywhere else in
america i can tell you that
ken coleman good hour thank you sir for
having me
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
send clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice and the paid off student loan
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice george camel
ramsey personality host of the fine
print a new podcast out on ramsey
networks is my co-host for this very
special theme hour
on the ramsey show as we celebrate the
launch of the new documentary borrowed
future we're going to talk student loans
this hour if you want to talk about
student loans you got a question about
student loans you have a success story
about student loans you think they're
awesome you think they're the most
horrible thing on the planet
uh you have an opinion about anything
you want to talk about as long as that's
that subject you call triple eight eight
two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five borrowed future is out of
the gate it has launched george and it's
already moving the needle and it's it's
climbing the charts and for good reason
i've already seen the feedback one woman
said she's watched it twice already
before 9 am that's impressive she was so
fired up about this she's telling
everyone about it her daughter all of
her friends it's one of those that you
can't help but you have to tell everyone
you need to go watch this today if you
don't know what borrowed future is it's
our new documentary it launches today on
apple tv on google play and on amazon
prime
and you can also watch it at
borrowedfuture.com and if you're a
teacher you can it's all a standard
documentary it's what 4.99 to rent it
whatever 8.99 to buy it or whatever the
normal thing is on that stuff and uh
just like anything else you look to see
a first class documentary on something
this is all about the student loan world
how the student how student loans are
basically killing the american dream
it's called borrowed future be sure you
tune into it again amazon prime google
play apple tv it's number two in the
documentary already today of all
documentaries on apple yeah so it's
moving you guys are watching it like
crazy you're sharing it if you're a
teacher and you want to show this to
your students it's free go to
borrowedfuture.com i'm going to tell you
that about a hundred times this hour but
it's time to talk about these student
loans and how out of control they are
george did you have a student loan yeah
i had 36 000 it was i think the average
at the time so i was very average hmm
how long it took you to pay it off uh 18
months once i got on this plan once you
got serious about it you knocked it out
fast yeah
i didn't realize you could get rid of
them i just thought it's something you
just keep as a pet uh until your adult
life and maybe take it to the grave if
you have to yeah i had 3 200
wow way back there it was 1982 right
and um
yeah and i had way more than that on my
amaco card
my gas credit card because in those days
if you went out in the country you could
buy a couch on your gas credit card i
mean it was you know crazy stuff so
uh but yeah it was a different different
world and certainly tuition was
different and
but uh so was the cost of living
gasoline was under a dollar you know
that a gallon and that kind of thing so
that's how long ago that 1982 was for
you people but uh student loans have
continued to grow to where it has become
and uh just a weight
on people to where they can't breathe
it's just so normal i mean most people
you meet that's the one thing you're
going to have in common is oh you've got
a student loan too great how much is
yours and then you laugh about it
because you can't fathom because you
can't cry about it but only so much
exactly if you when you can't cry you
laugh and so this is a huge issue and as
we explored this two years ago while we
were doing the borrowed future podcast
which you hosted which i hosted the
documentary team was just getting
started on this so this was two years
ago
and watching that team develop the story
and iterate and iterate to tell the
right story has been absolutely
incredible well we're storytellers here
and i gotta tell you when you're telling
a story there's a process to telling a
story uh if you're going to do it
properly there's a villain
there's a hero
there's a guide and there's a story arc
and there's a process you build to pull
someone through a story and we had a
serious problem with this documentary
there were too many villains
there were villains everywhere you don't
know who to point the finger at is it
sally may is it the guidance counselors
is it the parents is it the student loan
company
person who signed up for the loan the
person who signed up there's kind of
hard to blame them although they did
sign up for it but they're in just such
a pitiful horrible situation
and you want to cry with them rather
than beat them up yeah yeah we're not
mad at you if you took out the students
i mean i'm not mad at it you know i am
mad at the banks i think they're out of
control
um you know there's only been two or
three times in my career 30 years here
on the air that elizabeth warren and i
have agreed on something
and uh because i'm a capitalist pig and
she's a socialist um and uh she's a very
bright lady and i've actually had her on
the air here back in the day we were
fighting a bankruptcy bill that the
republicans put through
uh at the behest of the bankers and it
was a bad bill and it's a bad law and
it's still in place uh modification is
the bankruptcy law and she and i were on
the same side of that ted kennedy was
the three of us were fighting against
that and we all lost of course
uh and but she's come out today and of
course if you haven't heard uh
naviant uh six million student loan
borrowers are far better off after yet
another major company announced it will
shut down its services elizabeth warren
said like like elizabeth warren calls
navient to shut down come on elizabeth
you didn't cause this but yeah no one uh
no one is crying a tear that navient is
gone navient one of the largest student
loan companies unveiled plans to end its
federal loan services the student loan
industry on tuesday received yet another
major shake up when navient became the
third company to announce
its plans to end its federal student
loan program amid regulatory crackdowns
this year
senator elizabeth warren had one message
for the company good riddance
i would agree with you senator warren
navient has spent decades misleading
cheating and abusing student borrowers
the federal student loan program will be
far better off without them
the federal student loan program would
be far better off if it didn't exist
senator warren it has not been a
blessing to anyone except people like
navient and people like you
who used it to get votes
navient which collects the federal
student loan debt of 6 million borrowers
said in a press release that it's
working with the education department to
approve the transition of those
borrowers to another loan company called
maximus that's it that's
comforting
that's a comforting maximus what
interest
maximus interest that's scary maximus
screwjob
so you just get traded to the next one
can't make this up
they're gonna call it maximus
oh boy this is fabulous
this is what's wild richard cordray head
of the federal student aid office he
said earlier this month student loan
companies are choosing to shut down
rather than face more accountability
because they've been screwing people
they go hey this ship is sinking let's
get out of here well we we we didn't got
caught with our hand in the cookie jar
we got all the cookies out of this we're
gonna get we're gone baby we're gonna
get out of here before we end up the
subject of a federal investigation and
get more than shut down yeah that's what
that's what's going on here they're not
doing anyone favors but themselves here
yeah and i got to tell you the democrats
and the republicans uh did put pressure
on navient for its misbehavior and thank
you i will go along with you senator
warren uh good riddance to naviant
ciao baby
student loans we're bringing people from
across the aisle today bring all maximus
bring our maximus
maximus interest
[Laughter]
[Music]
maximus
oh i can't believe it
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com slash ken
sign up today absolutely free and let
zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
it's a student loan theme hour we're
talking student loans in honor of
today's premier launch of the new
documentary borrowed future
you can view it anywhere you view great
documentaries like google play
amazon prime apple tv and it borrowed
future.com stockton is with us in
phoenix arizona hey stockton welcome to
the ramsey show
good afternoon um i graduated graduate
school
a year ago with two hundred thousand
dollars student debt at seven percent
my question is
the recommendation is to get out of debt
except for a home the home debt is okay
what if my student loans is as much as a
home would cost is the recommendation to
still
pay off the student loans renting during
that time and if so that'll be
10 plus years
what's your graduate degree in
i'm a chiropractor
okay
and so what are you going to be making
uh i just started a job here in phoenix
85 000 a year
okay and so you you plan to pay 15 000 a
year on the student loans
yes
well that sucks
yeah
that's pretty lame you ought to pay a
lot more than 15 000 if you're making 80
and you should be making more than 80
as your chiropractic career grows would
you agree with me
yeah the hope is definitely to make more
eventually um as i grow in the company
and whatnot the other issue what did you
make but the year before you graduated
what was your income
50 000
associates in chiropractic don't can be
taken advantage of and i was last year
so i didn't make very good money last
year yeah okay so what if you lived on
35 000
and put the rest of it towards the
student loan debt
yeah
that was one of the reasons why we
postponed getting a home is is to
hopefully throw more money at the
student loans the only issue is to live
in a rental home where my wife and our
kids feel comfortable walking the street
our rental is 1600 a month and that
doesn't include the administration fees
the hoa fees and other fees associated
with
the renting so that's something that i
struggle with is being able to throw all
my money at student loans yet my rental
i feel like is taking more money than it
should i'll tell you as as a homeowner
it's very expensive and i'm not talking
about the mortgage payment versus the
rent payment i'm talking about home
ownership in general so if you can't
afford to rent you definitely can't
afford to be a homeowner and so what i
want you to do is focus on these student
loans first i want you to buy a house i
want you to have that american dream but
as we talk about in the documentary
student loans are killing that dream
because you've got this bear of a
payment in your life and you've got a
great income it's going to continue to
go up and like dave saying this thing's
gone three and three to four years from
now
stockton here's the thing
you have two choices you can go the way
that you're you're trying to your
emotions are taking you where you're
justifying this and you're figuring out
a way that it takes forever and so you
go ahead and buy a house and now you've
got a house payment and you've got the
cost of home ownership that georgia's
talking about and your career will move
along and it will take you 10 years to
get out of that or more
if you go that route or you can do the
thing that we have taught and many many
chiropractors have done what i teach
and they roll up their sleeves and they
say not today i'm going to engage in a
different
treatment program for the patient i'm
going to roll up my sleeves we're going
to do nothing around this house we're
not going to do anything except get out
of debt we're going to clean up this
mess so that as my career grows i get to
actually keep the freaking money instead
of sending it all to sallie mae navient
or maximus
so uh
this is going to be too much fun i'm
looking forward to the next decade of
this well and so uh yeah the uh uh yeah
but right now the the state of mind
you're in you're going to be in debt a
long time
because you bought the lie that you're
stuck and you bought the lie that you
might as well just keep this like it's a
freaking backache or you can do the i
just told a chiropractor like that i
just said that i did that on purpose
that was a metaphor that he would
understand and so yeah the uh i hope so
you you're gonna either engage in the
extreme measures
to get the extreme results or you're
gonna be normal
and i sound like you talking to one of
your patients
with the treatment program you put in so
you got to decide
physician heal thyself
sierra is with us sierra is in what did
i do there she's in uh did i did i i
gotcha didn't i got it i managed to pull
it off in san antonio hey sierra how are
you
i'm good how are you good now to back
story for our listeners you were here
just the other day with your parents who
did their debt-free scream they were
amazing you were amazing and we called
you back because of while they're doing
their debt-free screaming talking about
getting out of debt they said and oh by
the way
our daughter who was going into college
while we're getting out of debt
managed to go and get her degree debt
free
and you're an impressive young lady i
remember remember meeting you the other
day thanks for coming on with us
thank you for having me i really
appreciate it it was a lot of fun being
able to uh watch my parents tell their
story and then now i get the chance this
online so i'm super excited cool so your
degree is in what
i got a degree in marketing from where
stephen at austin state university in
nacogdoches texas vacuum checks there
you go and you
did this 100 debt free
how weird are you how did you do that
yeah so um it really all started with a
plan
that my dad and i put together
my senior year of high school um
it was getting down to the wire i pretty
much had
um my own plan actually figured out i
thought i did at the time
i had the school i wanted to go to i had
the acceptance letter i had you know
room and board figured out um
i just didn't have the money to pay for
it so that was the biggest uh thing that
i had to figure out
and so my parents sat me down and they
were like look you know we want you to
go to school we're just not going to go
into debt in order for you to do that
and so i kind of had to just come into
terms with the fact that
i wasn't going to have that first year
college experience that i was looking
forward to but there was a bigger
picture at hand and so my dad and i
devised a plan
and
we basically figured out how much it was
going to take or how much i would have
to save to go to the university of my
choice which was sfa
for the last two years so four semesters
we got that number and then we figured
out how much i needed to be saving
monthly
in order to reach that goal at the end
of my first two years at my community
college and so while i went to community
college for the first two years i worked
i would say
at least 40 hours a week every week and
i was saving pretty much my entire check
what were you doing what kind of work oh
i worked at a local grocery store and
you were how old
i was 17 at the time so 17 18 years old
you're in community college for the
first two years and you're working and
saving to do the last two years at your
dream school
correct wow
right so
is that what happened
yes i did i was making about i want to
say maybe 13 an hour
and i was able to actually finish a
community college a little bit early i
finished in three semesters instead of
four
so because of the high school credits
that i took
i mean the college credits that i took
in high school um i was able to finish
up so you did like some ap classes that
got college credit
correct they were like dual credit cards
which sped up how fast you got through
and was made you did not take those
classes so it saved your money
correct ding ding ding ding ding ding
wow
yeah so that helped me out a lot i was
able to finish an entire semester early
at community college so that last
semester i just worked i mean i was
working every day every night i actually
ended up taking on a second job because
the one job that i had i wasn't going to
reach my goal in time when did you
graduate
i graduated um i graduated high school
2016
finished community college in 2018 and
then graduated
um
from sfa this past may 2020. you got the
new marketing job
not yet
currently i work at ernst young one of
the uh big four accounting firms as a
financial analyst
right now but without the the mike
i make about forty seven thousand family
i love you you're amazing incredible
incredible okay key point
made a plan my dad
was a parent
my dad did two things
he took dead off the table
not an option
my dad
helped me plan you picked up on it
george yeah she made a plan
rachel cruz says we don't have a student
loan crisis we have a parenting crisis i
believe that moms and dads are letting
their 18 year olds run off into a ditch
and watching them do it
instead of grabbing you and going no
debt
plan no debt plan work
sounds like dad stuff sounds like mom
stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's a student loan theme hour here on
the ramsey show open phones at triple
eight eight two five
two
george campbell if you want to talk
about student loans this is your place
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host he is the current host he was
the original host of the borrowed future
podcast which actually gave us the
inspiration and the idea to turn it all
into a documentary and george did a
great job with that millions and
millions of you have listened to
borrowed future podcast uh i think it
was 10 12 episodes yeah it was eight and
now nine we released a bonus one today
oh bonus episode on podcast today yeah
updating everyone to go with the launch
on the documentary and of course he's
also the host of the new ramsey
network's production called the fine
print and you can listen to him there
all the time i want to go back to
sierra's story for a minute she's
incredible
a young lady comes in says i'm going to
go to college and i have no idea i'm
going to pay for it and there's no way i
have the money as if the money's going
to just rain from heaven which is you
you were interviewing some students some
high school students recently and you
started asking them and it freaked them
all out basic questions what it was
going to cost
what do they want to do what was it
going to cost how are they going to pay
for it and you would have thought it was
an interrogation room and i went oh my
gosh
their parents have never talked to them
about this stuff well their parents have
never thought about it either
they probably what are you studying
that's matters
and that you can get a job because you
paid money to get a degree
not i got a degree in left-handed
puppetry and then i'm shocked that i'm
serving coffee
come on
moms and dads you got better sense than
this
but sierra's dad said no you're going to
study
marketing
consequently she's got a job straight
out of college making almost 50 grand
and that young woman there she'll be
making double that in just a handful of
years i promise you
uh she's
incredible and then the second thing dad
did was he said no
we're not going to borrow money
which means that we need a plan
we need a plan so how are we going to do
this well she worked her tail end off oh
by the way working while you're in
college is not child abuse
call the ambulance
you don't get to participate in the beer
pong tournament you'll survive
you're there to get a degree to gather
knowledge this is what you're paying for
not how much alcohol you can consume
and whether the football team is good or
not will not affect your future career
they don't ask about that when you do
the job interview who knew
who knew
you know
yeah
it's conversation piece oh you went to
so-and-so and they suck at football
that's the only thing that comes up and
then it moved right along right oh my
god
you know and so the the the uh student
experience that we're paying 150 grand
for
somebody shoot me and get it this over
with really
instead we're going to end up with
maximus debt as us
that's the new lender if you maximus
debt is us navi just renamed them i just
renamed the whole thing i'm going to
have so much fun with this it's just
you're right it sounds like a villain
from a saturday morning cartoon maximus
dedicated that is us
i love it it's frightening
so parents moms and dads you can stop
this watch borrowed future scare you
straight scare your kids straight
and it'll also make you vote your
congressman out of office because
they're idiots they keep the student
loan thing in place and then they go
around we need to forgive student loans
well student loans are so evil elizabeth
warren that we need to forgive them she
tweeted that today by the way if we need
to forgive the student loans elizabeth
warren why aren't you passing
legislation to stop making them
oh that would be intellectually
dishonest oh wait a minute you're a
politician oh women you're a democrat oh
my god
seriously huh
are you riled up i'm riled up
we did it i have for 30 years worked
with people whose lives have been
screwed up by this
and it doesn't affect me at all yeah i
don't have student loans
like i said 3
500 years ago when the dinosaurs roamed
the earth nobody cares about my student
loan debt
but i tell you what talking these people
their lives unbelievable
carol is with us carol is in
philadelphia carol your student loan
question or comment
hi thank you for having me
i just had a comment about student loans
and my back story i am 46 years old and
i still have
101 000 left in student loans i was
double dumb and went back to college
twice and took out loans twice
um i just didn't know any better
before you know following dave ramsey
and personalities yeah
i still have to rent an apartment um i
only have a thousand dollars in my
emergency fund
i've never really fully been able to
invest i always thought investing was
you know for the rich people um and it's
just from my background neither of my
parents went to college they had no idea
what you know they could never teach me
what were your degrees in
well the first degree was in history
which if you don't go to grad school and
you don't want to be a teacher
is basically like left-handed puppetry
when you graduate so
and then i worked in an office in my 20s
and then in my 30s i decided to go back
i always wanted to be an architect so i
got an architecture degree um but i went
through a private school yes yes i'm
doing financially well how much do you
make next year
i am making 80 000. that's good okay so
now we're going to claw our way out of
this okay good
exactly exactly so um but i just would
tell anybody
don't take out student loans at all it's
not a good roi
you know sally mae is not in my spare
bedroom i'm living in her basement it
feels like right now
you know
she owns the house i'm just a tenant yes
exactly exactly um
and i i think people are so
they want to get done in four years and
they want to start their life and you
know at 17 and 18 i didn't know what i
want to do most people don't know what
they want to do at that age i think it's
better to take your time
work you know build your savings to be
able to go it's okay to go to school
part-time you don't need to go to the
party school you don't need to
live away from home it's just
you really have to think about it i wish
they would have taught it in high school
um
so yeah it's it's tough it's it's not
easy
carol i'm proud of you for facing the
monster i think you're going to win i
think you've turned the corner
i will win my goal is to get it all paid
off before i'm 50 because i do not want
student loans in my 50s there you go
that's a good that's a good goal and
you're gonna get there i mean it's four
years you're gonna make it you're gonna
do it that's 25 000 a year making 80
grand you can do that
and um i i got faith in you and thank
you for telling your story though
because it is a wake-up call and again
we go back to studying something that's
applicable
someone got an architecture degree now
that actually works hello
and studying something studying at a
school
see here's the thing okay
i'm not mad at you if you want to go to
a famous school and pay a lot of money
i mean 70 80 000 a year okay vanderbilt
right here in nashville 70 something
thousand bucks a year tuition
okay university of tennessee
in-state tuition state school twelve
thousand dollars
so is vanda are we saying vanderbilt is
seven times your income is going to be
seven times as much if you go to
vanderbilt as if you go ut
well i know this is not a fact because i
went to the university of tennessee and
people that weren't went to vanderbilt
worked for me
so i know the 7x thing doesn't work
and oh well i make connections with what
other broke people
who are you connecting with
other people who didn't have the ability
to look for a value now again i'm not
i've got relatives that graduate from
vanderbilt they're very smart and
vanderbilt is academically superior it's
not 7x superior no not even close
not even close and if you go
300 000 in debt to go there it's an
indication you're not superior
yeah your your lack of judgment is
unbelievable and so i'm picking on
vanderbilt but they're just an example
of one of the famous schools that's a
they're the southern ivy league if you
want to call it there's a lot of pride
and you went my my mom and dad went
there and so i've got to go hard to get
into it's right it's very prestigious
the football team well maybe not there's
not there but a lot of times you make
these decisions based on where mom and
dad went what the experience is going to
be like what the football team is like
not can we afford it and is this going
to get me the degree that i can get the
job in the field that i'm passionate
about we're not thinking that way we
took a call here on the air just a few
months ago a young lady in south
carolina was talking about going to
oxford to mississippi and i said why are
you going to mississippi instead of
south carolina it's 14 000 or more
because of out-of-state tuition
a reason the town is pretty
ah
i'm gonna lose my mind
where are your parents
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first peter 5 6
and 7 7 humble yourselves therefore
under god's mighty hand that he may lift
you up in due time cast all your anxiety
on him because he cares for you
martin luther king said no work is
insignificant all labor that uplifts
humanity has dignity and importance and
should be undertaken with painstaking
excellence
george campbell is my co-host today this
is a student loan hour as we celebrate
the premier launch today of our first
documentary it's called borrowed future
how student loans are killing the
american dream you can watch it on apple
tv
rent it for 499 google play
amazon prime or borrowed future.com or
you can buy it and download it like you
would a great documentary of other kinds
so be sure and check that out darnell is
with us in
huh raleigh north carolina hey darnell
what's up
hey dave i'm will how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
yeah so um i was calling because i just
finished watching the ball feature
documentary and it's gotten me thinking
about my student loans and my repayment
plan i'm especially considering that i'm
going to be graduating soon and i'll
have to start paying them
um
so so far my student loans have been
kind of in the background one because
you know i have four years to work on
paying them well to consider how i would
pay them
but i also went back to school right
after so um
so they've really been in the background
for a while but after watching the
documentary
it's kind of gotten me thinking of what
the best repayment plan is yeah how much
student loan debt do you have
right now i have 38 000 and i'm gonna
have to accept another five thousand to
finish off okay she had 45 000 give or
take by the time all this smoke clears
and your degree is going to be in what
um this will be my masters of business
administration good good okay when will
you graduate
uh may of 22.
okay all right and so well between now
and then what i'd prefer you do is work
your tail end off and let's see if we
can not take out any more loans won't
you see if you can cash flow the rest of
it that's the first thing let's stop
doing harm and then from there george
when he gets out and gets the job yeah
as soon as you get a job uh that money
is not going to go to you it's going to
go to lenders and you're going to work
your tail off probably get a second job
and get rid of this debt it's 43k if
you've got an mba and you're making 50
60k
you can get rid of this debt in two
years or less yeah
exactly so it's possible
beans and rice rice and beans dude you
don't come out and buy a new car you
don't come out and buy a house you don't
come out and spend a bunch of money you
don't come out and act like your top dog
you're not your bottom dog you've got 45
grand about in student loan debt you got
to clean up and that's so that's mission
one the quicker you knock that out the
quicker you get on with the rest of your
life and you get to benefit from this
education
the longer you keep this around it's
more going to be like trying to swim
with concrete concrete shoes on don't do
it we just took that call from the 46
year old still paying on her loans i
don't want that to be you darnell i want
you to have your entire adult life
student loan free
good observation
nadia is with us in houston texas hi
nadia
hi it's nadia nadia i messed it up i'm
sorry okay nadia my bad i remember
seeing you the other day on my
daughter's show rachel cruz
and you were impressive and i told them
to reach out and see if you would come
on thank you for doing that
thank you for having me now you went
through
school debt free tell us your story
right quick
absolutely i actually got my start in
community college through bureaucratic
courses when i was in high school i
started at 12 graduated from my with my
associates when i finished high school
at 16 and then went to my four-year
university finished off my four-year
degree in another two years and
graduated debt-free at team
with a degree in what
political science
okay what are you doing
uh right now i'm actually saving up
money so i can cash flow for grad school
and in hopes to become either a social
worker a social worker or a child
advocacy lawyer
okay
i like b
because i think you're incredible i i
was watching your your why i watched
your presence and your poise on the air
with rachel it was absolutely and you
currently are 20 years old i'm no sir
i'm 18. 18 years old i'm sorry yeah and
uh you attributed this if i recall to
your mom and dad being immigrants
um absolutely the drive my parents
placed in me was
you you are going to college you're
going to do it and we're going to make
it happen uh but you need to do your
part and apply the scholarship whenever
you can
yeah well you got your undergrad at 18.
that's that's i think that's doing your
part so your mom and dad immigrated from
where
jamaica from jamaica and they said we're
coming to america we're going to change
our family tree so by god you're doing
this
yes absolutely and one thing i
appreciate is they would never
helicopter parents because i know so
many people their parents are just on
them so much they don't have any room to
grow my parents are always like you know
what you need to do make sure you handle
your business and then we don't need to
be overbearing in any way they treated
you like an
adult absolutely i was 12 in in a
community college i was taking classes
with adults so well they're in that
respect and kept it yes sir so you're
are you uh have you been tested for
intelligence are you like a savant or
something
i have it i did skip to grades
kindergarten in first grade so i went
from preschool to second that was the
last time i took an educational test
like that
i can't skip lunch and she's just
skipping grades over here
you are very
you're
impressive
well i think i think you've got i think
you've got a high level of intelligence
but i think you've got a higher level of
uh drive
and really and that comes from a higher
power yes absolutely yeah no question no
question god being involved in your
all's lives and uh if you guys want to
hear more of uh nadia did i say it right
that time you sure did nadia's story you
can see rachel here on rachel cruz's
show
on youtube uh which comes up pretty
regularly that's where i picked it up
and i was i was just thumbing through
rachel's show and i'm like whoa look at
this young lady she's amazing so uh the
ke your your
thing was you worked your tail off you
went to community college you got
school credit for school classes you
were taking you rolled that up so you
didn't have to take as many classes and
you do the whole thing in four years uh
now did you get all scholarships or were
you working to pay for it
uh i actually got my first job when i
was already a junior at howard
university and i use that to pay off
some of my books and things and just
additional expenses due to the pandemic
but i didn't get a full ride from howard
a lot of it was external scholarships
like i mentioned on the show i'm not the
product but like these big 10 20 30 000
scholarships i'm the product of 50
scholarships and 100
and 200 because a lot of people snubbed
their nose at those but i was the person
like if there's any scholarship y'all
are going to give me i will apply take
my chances and keep collecting the
winnings so out of the total how many
dollars in scholarships did you collect
do you think
i don't know the exact amount but i know
with the other schools that i didn't
choose to attend in total the last time
i checked was over two million dollars
offered when you considered like the
tuition and full rides from other
schools i was offering yeah but the
actual when you add up all those fifty
dollar ones and all that and actual cash
dollars that went towards your school
well you think it's ten thousand or
fifty thousand
it's probably closer to fifty thousand
and ten yeah wow and how many different
scholarships do you think you had you
said you had a lot of little ones
well over fifty
yeah so they averaged under a thousand
dollars a piece yeah is the point yeah
that's what it's not about
20 000 scholarships and full rides
you've got to apply for the little ones
it adds up guys this can be done
you just have to pay attention and when
you don't pay attention to any area of
your life including your education your
kids education including your wealth
including your debt you wake up and
you're normal and your life sucks
and these people that have wanted this
were not zombies they did not sleepwalk
they paid attention their dads and moms
paid attention so this is what borrowed
future is about it's trying to get
america to pay attention to an epic
and epic failure called the student loan
program it is a failure it needs to stop
yeah you've got to make a decision once
you watch this documentary you have to
decide if you're going to be a part of
this system any longer if you're going
to let your kids be a part of that
system and your friends be a part of
that system so every living breathing
person needs to watch this documentary
the stories are inspiring there's some
heartbreaking stuff there's some amazing
experts featured on there and it's 90
minutes and it is a world-class feature
film documentary i'm so proud of this
team and what impact this is gonna have
yeah me too borrowed future again you
can watch it at google play
amazon prime and apple tv as well as
borrow future dot com if you are a
teacher show it to your class for free
uh and so far today we've had several
hundred teachers already sign up for
that which gives me hope you can do that
we gonna stir up a ruckus boys and girls
check it out that puts us our the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you